hi and welcome to goo
his life with me today is my colleague
morrow hype on tomorrow and we're
talking about today is the google wallet
objects API this is another video in our
series of videos about the wallet
objects API and today we're going to
talk about the wallet objects quick
start for Ruby the goal of these quick
starts is to help you hit the ground
running in your wallet objects API
integration in each of these quick
starts recover a few things we covered
hey how do you walk you access to the
resources we cover how to insert a
wallet objects class we cover save to
wallet and how to create a wallet
objects and lastly we cover the wallet
web service API which is how do you
enable discoverable and how do you allow
people to sign up for specific wheel LT
objects and to walk through getting the
Ruby quick start up and running here's
Mauro thank you Paul now let's go into
our documentation to get the
instructions on how to download install
and configure the Ruby quick start first
thing is go to our developers google com
commerce / wallet and then from there go
to the google wallet objects and click
on quick start samples and then Ruby
once you're there the first thing that I
recommend you do is watch the video that
we have on how to set up your account
your oath account and your and get your
credentials once you do that then the
first thing we're going to do is
download the sample code to do that
we're going to go into github our code
is open source and you can download it
or you can clone it from github to do
that the URL is github com / google
wallet / wallet objects QuickStart ruby
from here we can just copy the URL and
clone it or download it to our local
computer on my oh my my computer here I
have it already cloned so this is our
directory and these are the files that
we have for the quick start
and take now a copy of your private key
the one that you download it when you
create your credentials and copy it into
this directory in my case my private key
is called Wolf's private key that p12 so
this I already created it and copy it
into this directory now let's go and
configure and make make sure that we're
using the credentials that we got into
our project to do that let's open the
file called wasps constants that are be
so I'm going to open it here my editor
and I already have it here and from here
let's change some of these values the
first one is the service account email
address to get that you'll need to go
into the cloud on to your cloud console
here and then click on api's register
apps I'm sorry service account project
and from here this is your email address
that you'll need to use for your for as
a service account email address so I'm
just going to copy that and paste it
here in my file good and also now let's
get your issuer ID you can find that
from the merchant dashboard so in here
just by going into account management we
can copy/paste the issuer ID so we're
copying that into here and now go into
the service account private key for the
service account private key this is the
name of my private key but if you have a
different name you also need to modify
that the application name this value
doesn't need to match any of the values
that you have when you created your
account so in our case we have by
default wallet objects API demo and you
can leave that value there for the
origins this this URL is the URL where
we're going to be running the quick
start locally so we have localhost and
then port 8080 if you're going to be
changing the port then you need to
modify this value otherwise you can
leave it as is then we have four
different IDs for the loyalty class
object ID for the class object and for
the offers as well in this case you can
leave them assist or we can modify them
if you've been running the quick start
and you want to create a new class then
you'll need to change these so let's say
let's say demo one for each of these
once we have these we should be able to
run the quick starts but before we do
that let's make sure that we have our
prerequisites done here so first let's
check our ruby version so to do that
just run version and I'm running two
point oh you need to be running at least
1 93 so if that's good and you don't
need to upgrade your Ruby then now let's
move into our gems for the gems we need
to have four gems installed for this for
the quick start the we need to have Jace
on the Google API client the jaw and
Sinatra so let's run maybe you already
have some of these installed so first
let's run gem query local to see which
ones we have and in my case I have them
all I have Sinatra Google API client
JSON and jot if you don't have one of
these then it's very easy just do gem
install and the name of the gym so I can
do here json so since I already
installed them we don't need to do that
now once we have that we have the
correct version of Ruby we downloaded
the code we also have all our gems
installed and we modified our parameters
now all we need to do is just run it to
do that very easy we're using Sinatra to
run the server and we'll call it by
doing Ruby wolf server which is the name
of the movie script that we're running
and then minus P to say that we want to
run it on a specific port in this case
I'm running it on port 8080 so once we
run it now it's telling us that it's
running on port 8080 everything's good
Sinatra is running so now let's go into
our browser and see how this looks so i
have here we're going to go into local
host port 8080
once we run this you'll see that we have
the it successfully running now what do
we have in this page we have two steps
the first step it says insert a class so
either a loyalty class or an offer class
and then we have to save to wallet
buttons how does this work the first
thing that you do is that you'll need to
have a class for either or whatever
vertical you're working with so let's
say that we're doing the loyalty you'll
need to insert the class first and this
is only done once in the system you can
also of course update classes after
you've inserted them but you only need
to insert it once so this button will
will not be on your site this is only
here for us to test and show you how to
create classes every time you modify
something on the code but then after we
even started the class then you will
have button or you most probably will
have a button to save the card or a
coupon to the users wallet so this
button once we click it it will create
an object on my Google Wallet account
where I'm signed in here and then we'll
be able to see that on the phone on the
Google Wallet app so first let me create
the class by just clicking on that then
it says that it's inserted the class
loyalty class demo one which is how we
named it and now I go in to save card to
wallet and it saved the card already so
now when we go into our Google Wallet
app will see it saved and we'll do that
during our demo and they get a better
idea of what classes and objects are we
also have another Google developers live
video covering the concept of what
objects that you can take a look at now
let's go and look at the web service API
integration we also provide a sample
code for this in our quick start and how
this works is in if from the Google
Wallet app whenever a user clicks on
either a member or join the program what
Google does is Google will send the
information in a JSON request to your
web service then you will process on
your end to either create a new object
or send us an existing object is this is
a user that already has let's allow you
a loyalty
card with you send that information back
to us in JSON and then we will display
it on the phone so let's look at how we
can configure that in our discoverable
from here from the browser on the
merchant dashboard if i go into
discoverable you'll see here that i'm
going to edit it and there's a section
called merchant callback configuration
so in here you need to add the URL to
the host or you're running your Quick
Start sample and here we needed to be
running somewhere outside not on your
local site so it can be reachable from
our web service and from our service and
then the port and we recommend that this
is running over SSL for testing you can
run it over regular HTTP but for when
you launch the application needs to be
running over it ssl then the path to the
web service on our sample its web
service and of course you can change
that later to whatever makes sense for
you your application once we have this
will whenever there's a request then
Google will send the JSON request to you
and you'll respond back to it pong is
going to do a demo on how this works on
the phone and then we'll go over the
code and see where all of this is
happening in the sample all right let's
take a look at the phone this is the
latest wallet app and within this well
Apple if you see a few things this is
what we call the here now page as you'll
see I have one loyalty program that I've
joined and this occurred when Mario
clicked save this to wallet during the
demo so let's take a look at that walk
program first or let's take a look that
loyalty object first it's bacon restore
rewards this is our demo merchant and
within it you can see that hey I have
500 points that the tier i am is bold
that it's maru who joints and some
additional details that a merchant could
provide for their loyalty objects now
let's take a look at what a discoverable
is and the web service API
so in order to join a new program let's
say I'm in the store or something I
wanted to join your loyalty program i
get plus to find the loyalty programs
that are available to me this list will
also be sorted and they'll show programs
then the future will be relevant to your
location in this case I'm going to join
our test merchant which is easy bacon
recent rewards so let's take a look at
this discoverable and some details about
it bacon plus coffee your best morning
every day and yes I'd love to join this
one so I'll click join so all is all of
this information that you see now is
information that's populated from my
google wallet / google account I and
this information can be modified by
changing some conditions and the
discoverable that borrow just showed I
accept the Terms of Service and yeah
I'll take some promotional emails from
this merchant I'll create the account so
this will take a few seconds call back
to the web service that Morrow just
showed and then it will return it to
return in objects to the Google service
which will then push the object display
back down to my device in this case I
have a second card with a balance so in
this case maybe I could show this
balance and use it as my stored value or
something in the future so that's a
quick demo now here's Mauro to talk
about how everything works from the
discoverable there's one thing that we
need to make sure we have set up once
we're doing testing on our end is that
the status of the discoverable needs to
be draft if its draft that means that no
one can see it publicly but we can see
it on our testing on testing mode also
you will need to share if you go to
account management you'll need to share
with the account that you're using in my
case here G wallet demo is the email
address that clung is using on the phone
so as long as you get your discoverable
you set it on draft and you share with
the email addresses of the accounts that
you want to share your discoverable with
then you can use their own test mode so
it won't be life to anyone except you
when you're testing now let's look at
some of the code and see how this all
works out
I'm going to open here the editor and
for the Ruby sample we have most of the
code is included in the web server RB
file and what we're doing here is we
have first in this area we have the
authentication and we're doing that
using oath to you have your credentials
you have your private key in your
service account email address after
doing that we we have let me open first
the index.html so we can look at it when
we open the sample the first thing you
see is the index HTML page right in
there we have the two steps the first
one has the buttons to insert the
loyalty class and the second one has the
save to wallet buttons so on the first
one where we have the insert loyalty
class we can see that these buttons are
rendered in there here let me open it
here on this here on the jas file that
we are including within the index.html
file we are associating an action to
these when we click on the loyalty then
we're going to be calling insert /
loyalty the same for the offer button
here we're going to be calling insert /
offer then we also have when you're
calling the loyalty save or of offers
safe when the page loads this when the
page loads here where associate we're
calling JWT / loyalty and then worlds
are calling the job / offer for the
other button and what this is doing is
that it's rendering the g save to wallet
tag on the button which will based on
the the JS file that we're including on
the index HTML will render the nice safe
to wallet button that you see on the
page so how does this work when you call
the first let's look at the job for the
save to wallet button how this works is
that you'll go into the web server and
we'll find here the path we're saying if
you're calling God / anything then call
this and what this is doing is that it's
creating a job
and it's including the information of
the object that we're creating either a
loyalty object or an offer object so
this is what we're doing we're saying if
it's the type is loyalty then we
generate an object and then we add the
object to the payload and then we encode
the job and we just here we're just
outputting that so what it's doing is
that if you see the page when we load it
and you just you just inspect the
element you'll see that it has the jot
on the on the URL for that button then
also we have the insert if you're going
to insert a class then we also have if
you post to insert with the type what
we're doing in here is that we're
generating a class also based on the
idea that we created on the webz
Constance and then we're calling the API
here we're calling a REST API to insert
the app the class in this case and that
is returning back an answer and that is
displayed on the page on the index HTML
then the last path that we need to look
at here is the web service and this is
the one that was configured from the
discoverable and when you call
webservice what it's doing is that it's
checking it's getting in our case we are
assuming that we have success a
successful response all the time but you
can change this value to return a
different message so we're saying if
it's successful here we're going to
create a job and we're going to send
back on the payload that the result is
approved and we're going to send the
loyalty object back to to Google so how
this works here is that we're generating
an object here and we always generate
the same one for the sample but on your
case you would say oh it's a new it's a
new member so we generate a new object
and you generate this object on your end
and then you send back the information
to us and then of course you put it on
the on the payload and you encode it and
send it back the same way that we do
with the with the other path with a job
path if the response is not successful
then you don't have to send an out
object the only thing you sent back is
an error message and the result is
rejected in that case then Google will
display in an error on the Google Wallet
app we also provide on the sample other
parts to be able to list classes and
list objects and get specific objects
and those are just examples on how to
call the RESTful API s using Ruby this
concludes the google wallet objects ruby
quick start video we hope you found this
video helpful for more videos please
visit us at developers.google.com / live
wallet you can also find us in Google+
and or Twitter yeah thanks for joining
us for another week of Google developers
live see you next time